Amy?
Hi, I'm Cheryl Oberwood,
nutritionist to the stars.
Thank you so much for
meeting with me.
Phylicia Rashad has said
the nicest stuff about you.
She looks incredible,
right?
She's 90.
Wow.
Okay, I'm just
gonna dive right in.
I can tell by looking you're
not the least you can be.
Yeah, no, I'm not.
Well, we're
gonna change that.
So what are your fitness
goals?
Well, my goal weight.
I don't work in weight.
I work
in celebrities.
Which celebrity would you
like to be the same as?
I would
say Christian Bale.
"Machinist", "Metroland"?
"Newsies"?
I think "The Fighter."
Okay, now, walk me through
what you eat
in a typical day.
All right.
In the morning, usually
I'll have, like,
some yogurt
with some granola
and then at lunch,
some salad.
Okay-- Let me
ask you a question.
Yeah.
Have you always
been a (bleep) trash heap?
Excuse me?
I'm gonna find you
the perfect diet
You're gonna
stick to that diet
and you're gonna become
the perfect woman.
Okay, option one:
The Instagram Diet.
That's where you order
whatever you want,
take a picture
of it, post it,
throw it in the garbage.
Tweet it, don't
eat it.
I don't
want to do that one.
Option two,
the Beyoncé Diet.
You find out what
Beyoncé eats
and you tell
me all about it.
I don't know her.
Option three:
The Chilean Miners Diet.
Wow-- They're so
svelte.
Have you thought
about doing a cleanse?
What kind?
The kind where you
eat anything and everything
as long as you don't
swallow?
That's just anorexia.
Do you want a third season
of your show?
I do.
Okay.
The Tapeworm Experience.
Colonic Blastoff.
Um...
Cambodian Holiday.
Get Motivated.
Oh, what.
What's that one?
That's where you are arrested
without due process.
I don't think so.
Everest Drop,
The Great Depression.
Kentucky Meth Cycle.
Harriet Tubman
and the Underground Railroad.
No?
Tammy from "The Real World,"
Season Two, Wired Jaw.
Who are
your clients again?
Well, have you ever seen
the movie, um,
every
(bleep) movie?
I work with everyone.
(knocking)
Come in.
Hey, guys.
Hi, Angel face!
Amy, this is McClarty--
She's the new Bond girl.
Wow--
What diet did she do?
I just smoke.